one of the hardest parts about
containing the coronavirus is that we
can't see it by using Americans to wear
non-medical face coverings all we see
are its effects the symptoms the spread
the deaths how can you plan and prepare
for something that you can't see well it
turns out there is a way to see
coronavirus to see how it spreads to
look at its behavior there's a method
for doing this and this is the story of
how it works
[Music]
mapping an invisible killer like the
corona virus is a science and an art and
it's one that has its roots here in
London in the mid-1800s in London
loads of people were dying from some
disease that no one understood it wasn't
a virus like what we're seeing today but
either way it was spreading and killing
and no one really know how or even where
it came from so they came up with a lot
of theories all wrong which resulted in
a lot of inaccurate health advice from
using leeches to avoiding drinking cold
water to a bunch of other really weird
things that were totally wrong they
really had no idea what was going on and
yet people continue to get sick and die
and then this guy shows up his
proposition was fairly simple in theory
if we just track every single person who
gets sick and talked to them and hear
what they did for the day and where they
went and what they touch then we could
assemble a map of this disease and
understand it better this sort of data
collection like mapping out sicknesses
was not a huge part of medicine at the
time medicine at the time was much more
of a practice of smart doctors
performing really technical procedures
or giving health advice based on their
knowledge it didn't incorporate much
data science even still this guy Jon
Snow was diligent in his effort to
collect as much data about this
invisible killer as he could the data
pointed very clearly to this water pump
where people were getting their drinking
water every day turns out people were
drinking water that was contaminated
with human waste that was getting into
the water source here at this pump
they were being really sick with cholera
that was being transmitted through water
not through air this was a huge
revelation and was totally made possible
because John snow decided to go out and
collect a bunch of data from a bunch of
people
fast forward 150 years and today we are
kind of involved in a similar-looking
puzzle the new corona virus which has
now reached the United States firm that
first two cases of probit 19 to a sin
England donor virus yes Canada have its
first case at the new corona virus the
disease today is very different than
cholera in the 1850s it's a virus for
starters but what's the same here is
that this thing is spreading around and
leaving a deadly trail in its wake
except for in today's case instead of
trying to get visibility on a few
neighborhoods in London health experts
are trying to get visibility on entire
countries and the entire world humans
move a lot faster and further than they
did in the 1850s and because of that
something like this can spread a lot
quicker but with that has also come new
technologies that allow us to map a
virus in a way that we weren't able to
in the 1850s the New York Times put
together this really amazing
visualization using data published by
Chinese telecom providers it shows
people's travel patterns and helps piece
together a story of how people move and
how this virus left China and started to
move around the world as you see the
flow of people you can start to map the
spread of the virus once the virus gets
to your country the work of mapping it
becomes a lot harder let's say you live
in South Korea and you test positive for
corona virus health officials interview
you having you retrace your steps then
they verify with GPS signals credit card
transactions security camera footage to
reconstruct a map of everything you
touched every person you talked to buses
you rode on any opportunity the virus
had to jump from you
someone else local health authorities
are revealing the timelines and visited
locations of confirmed cora virus
patient's citizens are checking the
coronavirus locations and are avoiding
going to these areas they then isolate
every person you were in contact with
and interview them about everyone they
touched following the trail mapping out
the movements of the virus and trying to
get ahead of this thing that you cannot
see once in quarantine you can get an
app on your phone that tracks your every
movement ensuring that you don't go out
and your find thousands of dollars if
you do break this quarantine it's
laborious painstaking resource intensive
work but it's the only way to truly map
a virus and get ahead of it and places
like South Korea and Singapore have
poured tons of resources into doing this
and that's one major reason why South
Korea who is 50 million people and tons
of huge urban centers has a curve that
looks like this whereas the United
States has a curve that looks like this
so why does the United States have a
curve that looks like this why aren't
they doing the same sort of intensive
tracing that happened in South Korea or
Singapore there are a lot of reasons why
the u.s. is now the center of the
pandemic one of the big reasons is that
the US isn't totally willing to do what
South Korea did in South Korea there's a
pretty high trust in the government one
poll found that 86 percent of South
Koreans trust health advice coming from
their government in the United States
that's way down at 59 percent of people
who trust the health advice from the US
government
in addition Americans aren't super into
the idea of the government tracking them
tracking their every movement asking
them what they've been up to who they've
talked to where they've been going this
crosses a line of privacy and personal
rights that is pretty sensitive in the
United States as part of our culture and
our ideology and is not as sensitive in
places like South Korea so in South
Korea you have people who trust the
government and who are okay with the
government implementing these really
stringent intense methods for tracking
and contain
virus but honestly at the end of the day
the major reason why the u.s. is not
able to adequately track this virus to
get ahead of it is because we're simply
too late we did not act when there were
just a few hundred cases and now with
hundreds of thousands of cases we're too
late
this sort of intensive tracing the
investigations that tracing of contacts
takes a lot of effort and even just with
a few hundred cases when you get up to
hundreds of thousands of cases it
becomes completely implausible and
impossible to execute so for now we
don't have a map of the virus we don't
even have adequate testing to know
exactly where it is and how it's
spreading let alone containing those who
have been in contact with infected
people so we're flying a little bit
blind which makes it that much more
important for all of us to take these
precautions that we've heard over and
over again of distancing and facemasks
this is all we can do without adequate
data of where the virus has been and
where it's going we have to rely on
these widespread precautions to keep all
of us safe and to stop the spread so
don't go out wash your hands six feet
away face masks etc etc
without a map of the virus that's really
our only hope I hope everyone watching
this video has been able to stay inside
and find ways to make use of all of this
time not going out one thing I've been
doing a lot of this learning new skills
and learning about bread I'm learning
new animation skills and that fits right
in with a sponsor Skillshare Skillshare
is an online learning platform where you
can take classes on just about any topic
you can think of and now is a great time
to start to learn a new skill if you're
into animation like I am I can recommend
this course called animating with ease
with Jake Bartlet it's a fantastic intro
to creating more elegant and
natural-looking animations I use the
graph editor and a lot of the techniques
taught in this course in my animations
and I think if you're interested in
animation something like this will be
really really helpful because Skillshare
is sponsoring this video they're
offering my audience two months of free
skill share meaning you don't pay
anything for two months you can test it
out see if you like it you can learn a
new skill and after that if you do the
yearly subscription I think it's like 10
bucks a month or less which is just
incredibly cheap for the amount of
skills you can learn on this platforms I
really believe in this model of taking
your learning into your own hands on
your own time so check out scale share
go to my link in the description and
start learning something today stay safe
stay smart and this whole crazy thing
will pass I promise see ya
[Music]